what key moments in history of the 20th
century
do you think if something else happened
at those moments we could have avoided
some of the big atrocities stalin's
holomore hitler's holocaust miles great
chinese famine
the great turning point in in world
history is
is august the 2nd 1914
when the british cabinet decides
to intervene
and what would have been a european war
becomes a world war
and with british intervention it becomes
a massively larger and more protracted
conflict
so very early in my career i became very
preoccupied with the deliberations on
that day
and the surprising decision that a
liberal cabinet took to to go to war
which you might not have bet on that
morning because
there there seemed to be a majority of
cabinet members who would be disinclined
and only a minority including winston
church who wanted to go to war so that's
one turning point i often wish i could
get my time machine working and go back
and say wait stop
just think about what you're going to do
and by the way let me show you a video
of europe in 1918 so that's one can we
linger on that one that one
uh a lot of people push back on you on
in the
because it's so difficult
so the idea is if i could try to
summarize and you're the first person
that made me think about this very
uncomfortable
thought
which is uh
the idea is in world war one
it would be a better world if britain
stayed out of the war
and germany won right
uh thinking now in retrospect at the
whole story of the 20th century thinking
about
uh stalin's rule of 30 years thinking
about hitler's rise to power and
uh
the atrocities of the holocaust but also
like you said on the eastern front
the death of tens of millions of people
through the war
and also sort of the political prisoners
and the suffering connected to communism
connected to fascism all those kinds of
things
well that's one
that's one heck of an example of why
you're just like fearless in this
particular style of exploring
counterfactual history so can you
elaborate on that
idea and maybe why this was such an
important day in human history
this argument was central to my book the
pity of war i i also did an essay in
virtual history about this and it's
always amused me that
from around that time i began to be
called a conservative historian because
it's actually a very left-wing argument
the people in 1914 who thought britain
should stay at the war were the left of
the labour party who split to become the
independent labour party
what
would have happened well first of all
britain was not ready for war in 1914
there had not been conscription the army
was tiny
so britain had failed to deter germany
the germans took the decision that they
could risk
uh going through belgium
using the schlieffen plan to fight their
two-front war
they they calculated that britain's
intervention would either not happen or
not matter
if britain had
been strategically
committed
to preventing germany winning a war in
europe they should have introduced
conscription 10 years before had a
meaningful land army and that would have
deterred the germans
so the liberal government
provided the worst of both worlds a
commitment that was more or less secret
to intervene
that the public didn't know about in
fact much of the liberal party didn't
know about but without really the means
to make that intervention effective a
tiny army with just a few divisions
so it's perfectly reasonable to argue as
a number of people did in uh on august
the 2nd 1914 the briton did not
intervene after britain had not
immediately intervened against the
french revolutionary armies
back in the 1790s it had played an
offshore role ultimately intervening but
not immediately intervening
if britain had stayed out
i don't think that france would have
collapsed immediately as it had in 1870
the french held up remarkably well to
catastrophic casualties in the first six
months of
the first world war but by 1916 i don't
see how uh france could have kept going
if britain had not joined the war
and i think the war would have been over
perhaps at some point in 1916.
we know that germany's aims would have
been significantly limited because they
would have needed to keep britain out if
they'd succeeded in keeping britain out
they'd have had to keep britain out and
the way to keep britain out was
obviously not to make any annexation of
belgium to limit german war aims
particularly to limit them to eastern
europe and from britain's point of view
what was not to like
so the russian empire is defeated along
with france
uh
what does that really
change
if the germans are sensible and we can
see what this might have looked like
they focus on eastern europe
they take chunks of the russian empire
perhaps they
create as they did in the
uh in the piece of brestlitovsk an
independent or quasi-independent poland
in no way does that pose a threat to the
british empire in fact it's a good thing
britain never had had a particularly
good relationship with the russian
empire after all
the key point here is that the germany
that emerges from victory in 1916
has a kind of european union it's the
dominant power of an enlarged germany
with a
significant middle europa
whatever you want to call it customs
union type arrangement with
neighboring countries
including one suspects austria-hungary
that is a very different world
from the world of 1917-18
the protraction of the war for a further
two years
it's globalization which britain's
intervention made inevitable
as philip zeliko showed in his recent
book on the failure to make peace in
1916.
uh woodrow wilson tried and failed to
intervene and broker a piece in 1916. so
i'm not the only counterfactualist here
the extension of the war for a further
two years with escalating slaughter the
death toll rose because the industrial
uh capacity of the armies grew greater
that's what condemns us to the bolshevik
revolution
and it's what condemns us ultimately
to nazism
because it's out of
the experience of defeat in 1918 as
hitler makes clear in mind camp that he
becomes radicalized and enters the
political realm
take out those additional years of war
and hitler's just a failed artist it's
the it's the end of the war
that
turns him into
the demagogue
you asked what are the things that of
all avoid the totalitarian states
as i've said british non-intervention
for me is the most plausible and it it
takes out all of that malignant history
that follows from the bolshevik
revolution it's very hard for me to see
how lennon gets anywhere if the war is
over
uh
that looks like the opportunity for
the the constitutional
elements uh the liberal elements in in
russia
there are other moments at which you can
imagine history taking a different path
if
uh
the provisional government in russia had
been more ruthless
it was very lenient towards the
bolsheviks but if it had just rounded
them up and shot the bolshevik
leadership that would have certainly
cut the bolshevik revolution off
one looks back on the
conduct of the the russian liberals with
the kind of despair at their their
failure to see the scale of the threat
that they faced and the ruthlessness
that the bolshevik leadership would
evince
there's a counterfactual in germany
which is interesting
i think the weimar republic destroyed
itself in two disastrous economic
uh
calamities the inflation and then the
deflation
it's difficult for me to imagine hitler
getting to be
reich chancellor without those huge
economic disasters
so another part of my early work
explored alternative policy options that
the german republic the weimar republic
might have pursued
there are other contingencies that that
spring to mind in 1936 or 38 i think
more plausibly 38
britain should have gone to war
the great mistake was munich
the hitler was in an extremely
vulnerable position in 1938
because remember he didn't have russia
squared away as he would in 1939.
chamberlain's mistake was to fold
instead of uh
of going for going for war as churchill
rightly saw and and that there was a
magical opportunity there that would
have played into the hands of the german
military opposition and conservatives to
to snuff hitler out
over czechoslovakia
i could go on the point is that the
history is not some inexorable narrative
which can only end one way it's a garden
of forking paths
and at
many many
junctions in the road
there were choices
that could have averted the
calamities of the mid-20th century
you